all right last card down and dirty
king's bet dollar i'm in
in i'll see the dollar
raise at five you raised five dollars on
that
i called bob
queens full of nines
hey kid don't you know what a full house
is yeah and i also know what a psych out
is
i love this boy
you need to start your report this
weekend why it's not due till next
wednesday i have plenty of time
that's what you said last time no i
didn't yes you did i think you're
getting senile
watch your mouth young man i can't watch
it it's under my nose
hello what happened to you well
most recently i was hit in the head by a
door
but before that i was fixing the
satellite dish on the roof and i
kind of fell why didn't you just call
the guy
but for god's sake allen how do you
intend to look after him this weekend
i'm in excruciating pain but i
appreciate your concern
oh well you could have picked up a phone
and give me a heads up
pick up the phone judith i needed
barbecued tongs to take a leak
can you look after jake or not well
charlie said he'd look after him oh like
hell he will there is no way i'm gonna
let your degenerate brother be
responsible for my son
oh sure don't ask me what i want just
boss me around like you're
you're my boss or something
charlie would be fine have a good
weekend hey uncle charlie guess where
i'm finally growing hair
come on man i'm eating right here i'm
growing a stash
oh yeah look at that
hey full hot who's is it
yours really
yeah it looks great with the stash
you know it just occurred to me that i
have been feeling guilty because you
called off your wedding to mia so that i
wouldn't have to move out
but then when i did move out you didn't
call her
yeah so so you know why i think you
didn't call her
we didn't call her because the whole i
don't want to throw my brother out on
the street business was a very
convenient and noble excuse to get out
of the marriage
that's what you think huh yes that's
what i think that's what you think you
heard me that's what i think
yeah well think again
admit it charlie i've been beating
myself up buying you pie and hats for
nothing
there's pie
oh okay here's one of the first things
your uncle charlie wrote
teenage mutant ninja turtles
huh what do you think must have been
before my time
okay we're done here
hey hey hey don't put your juice box on
the piano it leaves a ring
how could a box leave a ring
it is good it is good i am
okay well that's the game
dad kill my allowance sure
here thanks here
guys are doing business with you wait
you're taking my son's allowance on a
football bet
hey when he wins i pay off you know
minus the vague
minus the vig you're charging him for
the privilege of making a bet
that's what the vig is dad duh
let's face it he's not gonna learn this
stuff in school i don't care give him
his allowance back
fine you get no allowance
that's your punishment for gambling told
you you'd do that
yeah you did
i was doing business with you
happy birthday magic set awesome
oh how lovely perhaps he'll grow up to
be a connie
it includes 14 different illusions that
will amaze and astound your friends
but of course your friends may be
smarter than mine
cool have fun at the magic castle aren't
you going with us
oh i wish i could but i got to go to
some clown's wedding
i'll try and come back for cake okay
thanks a lot rose oh you're welcome bye
evelyn
bye-bye thank you so much poor soul
i'm sure she meant well now
open grandma mr present
close happy birthday thanks a lot but
clothes god clothes
darling it's calvin klein
no it's clothes but baby sweetheart the
girls are gonna love you in this
what girls all right the other boys will
be envious
the other boys will beat me up
well there's just no pleasing you is
there
hi mom and there's my big boy don't i
get a hug
nope god you're in the lizard
boys hey oh hi helen
he uh he left his homework in the car oh
thank you hang on i have some bills you
need to pay
great but they're really big ones
hi alan
so you uh he must be judith's support
group that's funny cause uh
i'm kind of supporting her too
it's not funny ha-ha so much is not
funny
oh cookies maybe this will take the
taste of foot out of my mouth
so uh who's the little baker among us
mmm foot
oh can i have a cookie sure sweetie you
are
so cute i know
you have a girlfriend yet no i'm a
bachelor like my uncle charlie
so you're never gonna get married no as
long as i got
someone to clean my house and some
action on a regular basis i don't need a
wife
[Applause]
excuse me i don't want to give anybody
half my stuff
okay bye-bye okay uncle charlie and i
are leaving now
bye i'm trusting you to act responsibly
and go to bed at a reasonable hour
okay you know this is a
real turning point for you you're taking
care of yourself
you're becoming a man you do
boy it uh seems like only yesterday that
i was bringing you home from the
hospital
you were you were like a little wrinkly
pig with colic
yeah are you going or not
are you ready hang on
goodbye my son save it for the date dad
will you people quit going into the
caretaker shack
corey are you in here no you idiot
cory's been dead for an hour
man should have went to bed
[Music]
are you crazy well there are several
schools of thought on that
so we gotta let you stay by yourself
tonight huh why not i'm old enough i
don't need a babysitter
okay well then i'll leave you to your
movie
wait wait you don't have to go want a
pop clark
sure why not so
what do i need to know well basically
when a guy has half a face
you leave him alone
come on let's go i changed my mind
you took my money i'll give it back
jake we're here you may as well give it
a try yeah give it a try
who knows you might like it
i will never forgive you for this you
didn't tell me i'd be the only boy here
so the odds are on your side the odds
for what i'm 11.
i want to go home i thought we had a
deal charlie you can't make him stay if
he doesn't want to
i love you dad
all right let's get started whoa who's
that
your teacher come on let's go yeah dad
maybe we should give this a chance
hi i'm jake hi jake it's nice to meet
you
yeah um your uncle tells me you like
ballet
[Laughter]
seems overly complicated what
why don't they just make chips with the
dip party on them dude
that's a million-dollar idea
what is pre-dip chips
dude that's a million-dollar idea
what's a million-dollar idea it's an
idea worth a million dollars
boy i wish i had one of those
i can't believe they brought back these
in butt head yeah
those guys are like too stupid to live
[Laughter]
uh-oh that's my dad quick give me that
air freshener
this is bug spray dude
it says it's for roaches
[Laughter]
perfect
you